no estamos a salvo así pintan las
mujeres haitianas su situación tras el
terremoto que devastó la isla caribeña
el 14 de agosto
dejándolas en condiciones de
vulnerabilidad extrema
después de perder sus viviendas miles de
mujeres y niñas se encuentran obligadas
a aguantar en campos improvisados con
lonas de plástico y en muchos casos con
sábanas con led nativo la casa está
destruida no podemos vivir allí si hay
temblores podría derrumbarse por
completo hay muchas grietas me formé
temen agresiones sexuales según amnistía
internacional en los 150 días
posteriores al terremoto de 2010 al
menos 250 mujeres fueron violadas en
este campo donde 200 personas tienen que
vivir asignadas preservar su privacidad
es una preocupación
hola tenemos dolor ni siquiera tenemos
acceso a un baño no podemos orinar y
todos se están mirando necesitamos
espacio adecuado para lavarnos es
difícil lavarse incluso en la noche
puede ser antorchas en cualquier momento
no sabes si son de personas de aquí o de
otro lado porque es un páramo la ong
human rights watch señaló esta semana en
un comunicado que el gobierno haitiano y
los donantes deben tomar en cuenta las
enseñanzas que dejaron los errores
cometidos durante desastres anteriores
en sus acciones al terremoto del 14 de
agosto de 2021 a fin de asegurar que las
mujeres niñas y otros grupos marginados
puedan recibir la atención que necesitan
además del miedo por su seguridad las
mujeres a menudo a cargo de una familia
deben enfrentar graves dificultades
económicas
tengo tres hijos llevamos aquí debajo de
estas sábanas desde el sábado no podemos
ir a casa porque nuestra casa está
destruida ya no tenemos espacio para
vivir según naciones unidas
la catástrofe afectó a más dos millones
de personas